[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
[Música]
me siento muy emocionada
como recordar los sueños cuando tenía 9
al ver tanta gente compartidos y
añorando los granos
pegue unos cuadros descoloridas veía un
joven tan hermoso que en mis sueños me
manejaba por los pasillos viendo gente
así mirándome pero con mi ropa de mi
abuelita así chiquita ese era mi único
consuelo
algún día lo cumpliré pero pasaron los
años pasaron muchos años para cumplir
ahora estoy aquí
fui madre a los 16 años no fue tan
llevadera mi matrimonio con tres hijos
tuve que batearle al sol
pero pasaron siguieron pasando los años
un amigo me llama y me dice su si hay un
casting quiere decir pero ni siquiera
sabía la palabra que era casting que es
bueno ya iré pero necesitan a una señora
de poder pero ahora qué hago no creo que
quiera una señora de polera no mentira
debe ser me puse el deportivo de mi hija
y me presenté así
viene el director visitó está la señora
de poder no hay la señora de poner a
llorar que sé
dónde está la señora de poder
me levanto allí temerosa yo soy y la
pollera
no dije nada pero señor a veces su poder
aquí yo sólo voy a pagar el taxi
regreso y ha pasado unas horas ya seguía
la gente esperando
la señora va a pasar al frente usted va
a decir
como va a estar aquí entonces tiene que
decir he perdido a mi esposo a mis hijos
no han matado a mis animalitos pero en
aymara tiene que hablar tienes que
llorar
pero ahora qué hago nunca he pasado eso
y ahora que algo que como
entonces dado las vueltas que tiene 10
minutos para preparadas
qué hago
ya pues será por algo digo me imagino
también a otras cámaras agitamos de
fruta de mi vida y visto eso usted sabrá
que hago ya pues me he preparado
es que ya lo voy a hacer pero
he empezado a meditar los 10 minutos así
ya le toca señora su turno
empiezo a hablar en aymara le digo como
y nati está tan suma pitingo mccue
pájaros huevo en acá rojos y guayaba
entonces
ya señora está lista
vale
[Música]
entonces
y pasó al día siguiente
era la grabación
pero no tenías ropa que voy a hacer
ahora no tengo ropa para ir qué hago
entonces empecé a rebuscar las cosas de
mi madre de mi abuela tenía algunos
recuerdos de un poncho le tenía que
hacer poner el poncho de mi mantilla en
la blusa y así me fui
a la grabación
era como si me hubiera transportado
sin haber nunca haber pisado una escuela
de cine una enseñanza nada
pero así me lanza enganchado donde
empezaba a gritar y decir tú te haces
cargo de todo un colegio pero ahora
seguía desconcertada yo
he empezado a manejar yo conseguirme un
palo ahí cuando ya lo estaban
arrastrando a lavar orina empezado a
gritar y decir a nivel hay aquí un
cataclismo a ver termina
y así
entonces
y así siguieron la vida después me tocó
ser manuelita de santos marcados la
pasaron otros tiempos también ingresando
a centros de madre participando de
payasito cantando haciendo poesía
siempre amaba lo que quería siempre
siempre con decisión
entonces ingresé a un medio de
comunicación a trabajar entraba a
artistas de todo otra vez volvía en mi
alguna vez también en trata de dejarlo
porque
entonces no te pagaban ni un peso más
bien te estamos haciendo el favor a
ustedes decían tienen que estar aquí nos
hacían firmar unos contratos seguíamos
así entonces ha habido ya otro casting
para hacer la guerra de lago
allí ya conocía la palabra casting
vestuario
ahí es donde edad me sentía realizada
para más contar la platita
es decir ya no voy a pagar el derecho de
piso porque había pagado de dos años
derecho de piso además de miraban
también así las señoras que habían en
esa época
tú quieres entrar al teatro
tienes que bajar el piso voy a más
pero lo voy a lograr voy a entrar
y así pasaron
de filmación en filmación
y así he ido conociendo gente
también algunos anécdotas cuando hicimos
la película fuego de libertad director
indie que dice ya van a ustedes van a
correr van a agarrar piedra de unos
había caídos un chucho con peluca más
cuando conocí corre y dice no
donde hay piedad su gozo mismo abierta
esas cositas pasa también entonces ha
sido un poco duro también había casting
en algunas veces esas épocas no te
avisaban
no te decía siempre
te hacían a un lado eso es cosa hay que
vivirlo en carne propia para ser alguien
en esta vida
entonces
yo agradezco aquí a los jóvenes de
haberme invitado
y
de ser una mujer
la primera que ha sido
premiada por decirte esas emociones
unique
de viajar a parís de conocer tanta gente
de ser como estratega es de todo el
mundo te mira te dice una fotito una
fotito
y yo me sentía así pero que siempre
tanto
bueno estoy aquí soy una persona humilde
que quería compartir las experiencias
decirle termina de estos jóvenes porque
están aquí porque aman lo que es
twittean aman lo que hacen a mango que
trabaja entonces siempre ser decididos
en esta vida
perseverantes en lo que hacen
porque si había una vez mi profe me
decía sushi porque darle el valor estaba
muy enferma no podía caminar cuando no
vas a llegar aquí
sabes las respuestas por muerto
mientras estés viva cojo vas a entrar
aquí entonces yo llevo eso
a veces no hay plata para los pasajes
entonces
tengo que llegar a pies y cumplir
entonces vuelvo a recalcar
amén lo que hacen siempre hagan
compasión querer mucho lo que están
haciendo ustedes estudian ser un
chocolate rocían el mejor no del montón
entonces
un buen albañil un buen arquitecto un
buen ingeniero
amén amén lo que están haciendo
y un día se verán aquí como yo en
alfombra roja feliz
feliz
y estoy cumpliendo cada uno de mis
sueños cada uno
porque les digo soñar no cuesta nada
pero realizarlas lejos ese es el detalle
el próximo sueño que realice será
conocer
al joven de mis sueños
y lo voy a hacer
porque ese es ese cuadrito así ya
viejito amarillo había sido roberto
carlos
eran roberto carlos más tarde vi y era
roberto carlos y me le ha prendido a la
leche
una es trujillo puedo cantar si ustedes
me lo permiten
aquí los organizadores también porque me
arrastro a tus pies porque me doy tanto
a ti y porque no pido nunca nada a
cambio para mí tú eres el grave problema
que yo no sé resolver y acabo siempre en
tus brazos cuando me quieres tener
[Música]
los llevaré siempre cada uno en mis
corazones aquí porque tengo mucho para
cada uno porque en cada personaje de
sembrado
y gracias a los organizadores por
invitarme aquello participe aquí que me
conozcan un poquito de veces siempre
decimos nada películas nacionales pero
te llevan a la palestra
tomemos un poco cada uno de todo lo que
tenemos en bolivia
gracias
como decía mi director susanita has roto
las barreras
gracias
[Aplausos]